oh yeah this trailers out you knew I had
to talk about this [ __ ] why is it the
Planet of the Apes was one of my
favorite movies the year it came out so
dawn of the Planet of the Apes trailer
yes please and this movie looks like it
is in the thick of it the shift between
who's running the world is going from
humans to Apes Gary Oldman comes out and
he gives a monologue he's like we have
had a shitty time we spent four years
fighting a virus four years fighting
each other which is pretty much Jim
Gordon coming out being like yeah that's
what happens when you disappear for
eight years Batman between The Dark
Knight in the Dark Knight Rises Caesar
takes over Hail Caesar and people look
scared out of their minds because
obviously they're probably fighting apes
it doesn't show much of the apes in this
movie again it shows the tone of the
movie it shows human beings are like
we're eating this dude does the
ballsiest thing ever he goes into the
middle of the woods he's like I need to
speak to Caesar to be clear he just said
he needs to talk to this dude Caesar has
the war pain it's all backing out from
his face it's almost like a parallel of
the Rise of the Planet of the Apes
trailer you see Caesar and he's kind of
giving a look like this is the cameras
panning and then he looks over you could
tell he's intelligent
this one it looks like he's intelligent
and he's really not messing around he
has his hand up like there's all the
apes are behind him he's just like Roy
and all the Apes just jump like they're
gonna kick this guy's ass knowing now
trailers are it's probably a completely
different scene entirely but you get the
point Caesars permanently scarred
because Malfoy was spraying them with a
hose and [ __ ] so now you know what done
I'm done
war pain I'm gonna kick your ass and
take over Earth I love an origin story I
don't know if I'm gonna like this more
than Rhys at the Planet of the Apes but
also like a good story of conflict and a
solid post-apocalyptic kind of vibe now
saying this is supposed to pocalypse I'm
saying the Apes are taking over so might
as well be so Donna the Planet of the
Apes hell yeah so dawn of the Planet of
the Apes have you seen the trailer what
did you think about it what have you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more